speaking of the notion of alpha
um share screen I'm going to put up that
tweet that you shared
um M the one that Williamson was going
on about yeah you just yeah I mean let's
just read it here he says never be
vulnerable in front of your girlfriend
is common Manos swamp advice which I
think is reasonable advice it it you
know you you like you deal with tears
you know with your girlfriend if there's
a family member that dies you know a dog
dies something like that most other
things you can you should be chopping up
with your friends uh the guy I was
talking to is more Alpha than pretty
much any other human that's ever existed
and yet he told me a story about how he
sawed on the bathroom floor in his
girlfriend's arms when the pressure got
too much for him then he got up dusted
himself off and went out to dominate his
challenges and become a world champion
here's the thing hiding your
vulnerability from the world doesn't
make you less vulnerable it just makes
you less honest and he goes
on like Williamson's got some good
conversations and guests but he won't
touch
anything that I talk about with a 10-
foot pole he's afraid to like I've like
I've engaged with him and the
acknowledgement as far as anything in
that space is is very limited so do you
want to explain what you were talking
about over here so I I saw a good bit of
this interview so he's talking about
Chris Bumstead who is a bodybuilder he's
won the Mr Olympia the classic physique
for the last I don't think he's for like
he's he's probably one of the biggest in
the biggest name in modern bodybuilding
right now um what is the classic
physique is that steroid tested or or
not they're all they're all tested but
it's um I couldn't tell you all the ins
and outs of it I mean there's there's
gear for sure though he doesn't look but
yeah like but he's he's also very famous
for having a very
um simple uh protocol where he's only
doing yeah he's Canadian so and where he
only does maybe like you know 500 grams
and blasts a week where there's some
people that are like over a thousand so
so that's part of it but he's got a
YouTube channel he's um yeah that's
Chris bumpstead so he's you know got his
channel he's got this content dating the
life stuff but I I saw that interview
and there were you know because I knew
specifically I watched this segment and
now this was a couple months ago so I
don't remember everything off the top of
my head but um I remember the story he
was telling where you know he was coming
up on the Olympia he was in the last you
know couple weeks of his diet
and most people have never done this
before I mean and what happens if you
talk to people that have gotten down to
ridiculously low levels of body fat
we're talking about like sub six% you're
talking like four five percent 3% for
these bodybuilding shows is that you
have no energy you have no libido it's
it's incredibly unhealthy to be at that
low of body fat percentage it's
incredibly unsustainable never see it's
exhausting you have no energy you have
no libido you don't want to do anything
um it just you feel like constant
garbage and so you know for him it was
like he had a moment where he's like I
don't know if I can do this I don't know
if I've got what it takes I'm not sure
if I can get through the next couple of
weeks and he had this moment in the
bathroom where he was crying his
girlfriend was coddling him and stuff
like that
and all I went back all I could go back
to you know this is one of the think I
watched this Tate interview that he did
a couple a year ago with this woman I
don't like I think her name was sha man
or sh something but the idea is that
this guy only gets that leeway with his
woman this guy Chris Bumstead only gets
that leeway to be able to do that
because of who he is what his status is
what he's accomplished this is a world
famous worldclass athlete in his field
he is nationally recognized as a top
tier alpha male for the Dum Dums out
there that you know but my whole thing
was it's there's a reason behind it I
mean this is not you're not if you're
Joe Schmo you're not Chris bump this is
this isn't you but I guess my issue with
Chris Williamson is that it's always
funny to me how people on one hand will
say will use the term Alpha as a
punchline and they'll make fun of people
for using like Co yeah real Alpha and
then they'll turn around and say that oh
well this guy's the most Alpha person
and that's basically what he said he's
like this guy's like the most Alpha
person that's ever lived basically and I
wanted to say like actually sorry dude
like no like yeah man I mean he's done
great feats of you know physicality and
he's a is a world champion bodybuilder
but um you know so I just think it's
tired when you have you want to see
something
funny yeah go sorry to
interrupt uh so I just looked him up on
Twitter he actually follows me so so he
knows about that's that's really
interesting that's really
interesting that's super interesting
maybe we gotta I wonder what I wonder
wonder what brought him to hit the
follow button on my account that's super
interesting yeah we got a maybe set
something up maybe to here I'll shoot
him a DM right now do it what was the
what was the criticism guys that he
brought down crying in front of his
girlfriend he's basically saying like oh
well everybody the manosphere is wrong
saying you shouldn't be vulnerable
shouldn't cry in front of your
girlfriend because this guy Chris
bumpstead did it and he's a world
champion so if he's allowed to do it so
can you it's just very much all is
feminism nonsense it's just like okay
but also the criticism was to to to wrap
it up was just and again it's it was
more of you know if you're so worried
that your girl is going to leave you or
think you're weak or whatever and cry in
front of crying in front of her then you
just have the wrong girl and she's just
not like the one for you it's just very
old tired advice that we always hear
from from dumb Dums that don't know what
they're talking I my analysis is that
you know if you're having a real hard
time as a dude and you you know you have
a network of guys like us and you end up
breaking down in front of guys like you
know if we were together and I was
having some stuff and I ended up in a
pilot you know on the ground you guys
would probably respect a man more for
doing that in front of you guys and not
doing it in front of his girl you know
I'd be like guys I'm I'm I'm anti
straight at the moment this is happening
this is happening and I'm not going to
go to my girl because that's a weak move
from you know because what is she gonna
do you know I mean look
like I I remember I was chatting with
and I I've run some polls recently with
some some ladies for some things we I
did one this past Thursday talking about
who's goingon to pay for what and this
and that and a couple of women you know
messaged me after and we had some
conversations about some past dating
history and some things and one of them
was just like you know it's hard dating
she's in her early mid 20s she's like
it's super hard dating guys my age
because they don't kind of know where
they're going but what's weird is that
so many of these guys will be extremely
forthright about that on the first date
or second date and admit like yeah I
don't really know what I want to do
don't know where I want to go you know
I'm stressed about money and she goes
yeah I don't like that and not because
she's a gold digger and not because
she's like oh I need a guy that's rich
because she almost this is what she told
me but you know maybe she could be
abolishing a little bit but her her
stance is that she's like well how are
you going to date me I cost money I
don't want to be a burden on you you
know I feel guilty for wanting to be a
woman in a traditional woman in a
relationship or dating where I expect
the guy to pay for stuff I expect him to
be put in the you know foot in the bill
which is a lot of them most of them that
expect this so it seems like there's all
the information that people are telling
men is like share everything be
completely open and honest with the
girls and that vulnerability and honesty
will make them love you and it's just
okay it's the it's the worst advice
whenever a girl asked you to be
vulnerable say do you mean vulnerable
like I dropped the soap in the prison
shower or emotionally and that us that's
basically where they're going to take
you eventually if you keep listen to the
advice yeah yeah yeah um there was a
there was a clip to a Sadia con
conversation with another G I didn't
recognize her but she was on a podcast
interview and they were talking about
vulnerability and and cheating and
basically like the six- minute segment
of that clip just boiled to down to men
need more friends and need to be able to
uh talk to them more right like they
need to be more emotional about stuff
and they got the part right about
talking to men about stuff but the
emotional part is like there's a lot of
[__] that you can like you I going to
tell you something right now there's a
lot of [__] in your life that you
can work through by hopping on a
motorcycle by going to the gym and
lifting weights or by going you to a
dojo and hitting [__] you really don't
need therapy for the most part being
emotional is a straight line towards uh
contempt it's definitely a a a the
fastest path to content with a woman
because there's nothing that turns off a
woman more or dries her up faster than
you being a a [__] I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clip's from if
you're new to the Channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out